Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burn his time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast and
just checking in on you.
Oh Jesus.
That took a lot of energy right there.
He probably like build g.
She sounded so fucking old to past couple of weeks,
kid.
What happened?
I'll tell you what happened.
Oh,
freckles is off the road.
Yes,
the old fucking [inaudible].
He ate what he used to be.
Hey,
what?
He used to be eight going to lax.
I love it.
I ain't doing fucking shit.
So fuck.
Call me.
I'll tell you right?
I,
if I had the fuck if,
if,
if we weren't in a never ending 17 fucking wars right now and they weren't
fucking taken such a giant fucking,
I literally give these clients more than I make and I did a fucking job.
Uncle Sam going onstage telling any fucking jokes.
He's like a fucking character comic.
That's what he would be.
This big stupid fucking hack,
you know,
going up there.
It's like he's on a fucking unicycle.
I want you here.
I want you to go fuck yourself.
How about that Sammy?
How about I get to keep just a little,
just how about a cunt hair more.
Sorry.
Anyways,
what am I thankful for this weekend?
I'll tell you right now,
dude,
if,
if there was a,
if there was a fucking way that I could figure out if I could figure it out,
how to get off the fucking hamster wheel,
you know,
because the deal is,
it's like you keep running or we're just going to tax the shit out of you.
You want to put your fucking money on the cook crap table.
We'll give you a little break,
you know?
But if you hit the second,
you start slowing down,
you know the government's just like,
wait,
and does this mother fucker think he's going to retire?
He's just going to coast.
You're going to get in that fucking car when you go into work,
you fall,
confuse your shit and you're going to fucking work and then we're going to take
more than you fucking make you smoke.
Unranked good.
Hey smart.
Nup that's what they should do.
Just come in like that fucking guy there and casino.
Smarten up by.
Take your head and I stick it through that fucking hole.
That's basically their vibe.
So anyways,
I figured out how to retire.
I saw it today and I was walking out of the grocery store.
So this guy had a Ford F150 with the camper on the back and I'm like,
that's it right there.
They'll let you do that.
Uh,
you don't want to work then you've got to live like that.
All right chicken and was still going to give you tickets and eventually we're
going to tow your house away.
Hey,
if you are in that situation,
if they show up,
can you take the camper off the back and then they just take the truck,
you know,
you probably couldn't have the bit,
well yeah you are.
You kick the camp,
but right here you're going to have to move that and he fucking you getting
underneath it.
Like those old school guys that put the refrigerator's on their back and you've
got to fucking start traipsing down the street,
you know?
Then you set it up and then some dish with the house like me.
It's just like,
um,
have you seen the guy down the street with the camper?
I don't want that in my neighborhood.
Um,
anyways,
what I'm trying to say is I really enjoy time off and having a great time just
hanging with my dog,
hanging with my wife.
Threw down yesterday,
you know,
all the relatives came over.
Everybody fucking April freckles.
I didn't go too hard.
It didn't go too hard.
I stayed away from the desserts,
you know,
I,
uh,
I did pretty good.
Then this morning I woke up,
I had my little parfait butter,
right?
I had the fucking,
uh,
you know,
a little bit of Greek yogurt with the fruit in there,
like the big fruitcake than I am.
And then I add a little hummus wrap for lunch in between them having a fruit
with,
you know,
it's holidays.
They get me this year,
finally figured it out after 50 fucking holidays,
finally figured it out.
Oh,
this is the problem.
I got to go.
Easy going to go easy this Thanksgiving weekend.
All right.
I had my thanksgiving dinner,
I hadn't,
you know,
around three in the afternoon.
I was halfway through the plate and I was already leaning.
Oh,
it was good.
it was delicious.
And um,
you know,
when you put your plate together,
I'm not white.
I hate those fucking people is I can't have my food touch other third.
You know,
the only thing worse than the person saying that is the fucking meathead across
the table.
Why?
It's just all gonna be mixed up.
Can you stomach right?
Both of those people should get in a car and drive off a cliff.
No.
Come on bill.
You should give thanks for both of them.
Anyways,
I don't give a fuck about that.
But I will say this,
when you put together your Thanksgiving plate,
this is how it has to,
this is how I do it.
All right?
But four o'clock,
you've got your Turkey.
Okay,
it's three o'clock.
You got your potatoes.
That way you can put the gravy on both.
All right?
And then it at five o'clock,
you know,
you want your,
uh,
let me move those all up an hour.
I'd say five o'clock is the Turkey.
Four o'clock is the mashed potatoes.
Six o'clock is your cranberry sauce.
You know,
it gives it a little nice little sweet kick with the gravy and the Turkey.
Get your potatoes in there.
That's good.
The fucking vegetables.
You know that somebody made that.
You just try to make them feel good,
you know?
Yeah.
That's shit all goes up around 12 noon.
That's shit that you're going to be like,
fuck,
I still got two more mouthfuls of that.
All of that shits up.
Uptalk that casserole thing that your fucking aunt makes,
you know,
make sure you get some cashflow.
You're sitting there with your fucking itchy sweater it right.
Then a,
what do I got?
What else is stuff?
Then you get whatever's like the sweet shit.
I keep around,
you know,
that's around 11 o'clock so we made some yams or something like that.
Sweet potatoes are simple shit like that.
You put that up there.
Then you got your bread somewhere around eight 39 o'clock you know what I mean?
And then right in the middle,
I don't know what else.
That's some of the fucking thing.
You just stick right in the middle.
Uh,
and then you just,
you just,
you eat it like the way you tune a snare drum.
And he drove us out there.
If,
you know the,
the whatever,
there's a million different patterns,
but that's basically the way you do it.
Um,
and I want to just take some time here to say how bad I feel for people who
don't live in the United States of America.
So you don't have this holiday.
Well,
you can sit down and eat way more than your fucking chair.
Um,
oh,
it's great thanksgiving.
It's fucking awesome.
And cause,
you know why?
Cause then you got the Friday off to just lay around,
you know,
with your belly poking out of the bottom of your fucking sweater that you passed
out in,
you know.
Um,
I actually,
you know,
uh,
was had to like,
I'm one of these lunatics one just so I tried to like make sure everything
fucking gets on the table.
It's all hot.
It's already to go.
I finally realized this year it's just like there's just too many fucking people
cooking.
It's just going to come the way it goes or whatever and then I realize anything
that needs to be hot,
you just put gravy on it.
It's going to fucking heat it up again.
And it was probably the best thanksgiving I've had in years.
But what's great is the Friday after the Friday after like today,
you don't have to go to work.
Hopefully,
you know you get to lounge around,
you know bleary-eyed from whatever the fuck he did the night before.
And then tomorrow you got all the college football games.
What do we got?
What do we got tomorrow?
Come on people.
You got Michigan,
Ohio State to kick off the day.
You got Alabama verse op and watch a five going to be a good game this year.
But you know,
who knows if Auburn winds that,
I mean Jesus Christ,
they,
they'd be going fucking nuts.
I mean tomorrow is the day.
You're not a man tomorrow unless you're ignoring your family.
Okay?
That's the level of football.
It's odd kid.
But I got my kid.
You heard my Kiddo.
She says it now.
She goes,
Fuck Paul.
[inaudible] Paul.
Now she wants now she wants it to be on the TV.
I'm fucking,
I'm steering her away from uh,
she always wants to see a Minnie mouse.
He goes,
Mimi,
meow,
meow meow.
Sounds like she's in a Mimi.
Mao Meaning Mao.
Like what's that?
Was that the deer Hunter Mau.
Mau,
right?
Meaning Mao.
Mimi.
Wow.
No,
Minnie mouse went to sleep.
Mimi Mau.
Um,
have I lost my mind?
What the fuck am I talking about?
I don't know.
I have no idea.
How much time have I done?
Eight minutes and 45 seconds.
Jesus Christ.
Some days,
you know,
this podcast flies by and then other days feels like I did eight in 45 minutes.
Um,
yeah,
Michigan,
Ohio State,
Michigan.
They got to get it dead.
I can't believe this is already the fifth fucking time they've played Ohio state
with Jim Harba.
Unless I'm wrong,
I have no idea.
Um,
but it's going to be a great game.
I like big 10 footballs,
you know,
it's old school football.
You know,
they actually run the fucking ball.
I got to tell you that shit.
And I don't want to be a grumpy old man here.
Um,
that fucking game Monday night.
Kansas city versus the rams.
The amount of people that were freaking out though,
who gave him the scene.
Yeah.
That game was a shit show.
That game remind me of the Superbowl last year.
And I think that that's basically the direction NFL football is going in,
where there's just going to be no fucking defense.
In.
My favorite thing about me saying there's no defense,
but people,
oh,
there was three defensive scores.
The deck dude.
MMM,
yeah.
That,
that's just like,
let's just like last year,
last year in the soup,
excuse me,
there was a fumble that won the fucking game.
It's like
the fucking rams gave up almost 500 yards fucking passing.
There was almost a thought in six touchdowns.
The guy to put six touchdowns in fucking 500 fucking yards.
Basically.
There was a total like tent passing touchdowns.
It was over almost a thousand yards.
I think they went over a thousand yards combined.
Okay.
It was a fucking joke.
And then everybody say to me like,
I'll bill,
you don't what you're talking about.
You just worried about your patriots,
which is hilarious.
My patriots had been thriving during this era.
We haven't had a fucking defense since 2004 a lights out when the game 20 to 17
defense we have and we've had to fucking score like 35 fucking points to win
Goddamn game since forever.
Um,
I'm just saying like if you're going to sit there and act like this is just me
to,
Richard Sherman was tweeting about it.
Another guy on the uh,
uh,
fucking Texans,
even Teddy Bruschi actually I actually saved his,
I did a screen shot or what he,
he basically said the way the game is now,
Richard Sherman is like,
all they all,
they want to see his points because what that does is that gets the casual fan
and the people that don't understand football,
who said,
don't fool.
Fuck no blue.
I mean,
that's what to be honest with you.
If,
if soccer ever wanted to make it into America,
they should be doing what at the NFL has done to their game,
which is just,
I don't know what they just took.
Think about every era,
right?
There's been a Jack Lambert,
then there was [inaudible] Elliot,
Lawrence Taylor.
I'm just picking some of the guys I can,
I can off the top of my head.
Uh,
Ray Lewis,
Ronnie lots,
Mike Haynes,
Lester Hayes,
fucking lunatic.
You know Andre Tip,
it's just lights out Bruce Smith's like where are those guys now?
This like maybe three of them and then not putting up the fucking stats those
guys used to put up.
You know,
they just,
I dunno,
they used Reavis island.
There's just not that guy anymore.
They can't,
they can't,
like those guys wouldn't be that guy today.
All right,
they'll shut the fuck up.
No,
but I'm just,
I'm just fucking saying.
All right.
Here's his,
his Teddy Bruschi.
Welcome to the new NFL.
When it comes to defensive football,
former linebacker,
teddy Bruschi wrote on Twitter or offense will move the ball and score.
That's it.
They're going to move the ball and score.
You can't do anything about it.
He goes,
make a handful of plays a game to take the ball away and get your offense.
A couple of extra possessions.
Score on defense is an a plus.
It hurts to write that.
All right,
so while you fantasy football,
play in fucking guy,
if you're going to fucking sit there and say I'm wrong about this,
then you're saying Teddy Bruschi is wrong.
Um,
I hate it.
I hate everything that they'd done.
I hate that the out of date.
There's no two line pass and hockey anymore.
I hate that.
It's just the stretch pass is up and down the fucking rink.
Um,
okay.
It's just,
everything's like,
you know what?
And I think it's probably because of like smart phones and everybody's fucking
looking at all the videos that you need to sit there.
Like a fucking,
I dunno,
a journal that forgot it's jacket.
I'm trying to think of some animal that shakes.
I don't know.
Don't,
don't listen to me.
I'm just saying,
um,
dude,
that fuck I'm home's guy is a fucking star.
All right?
But you know,
they both look like Dan Marino.
Yeah.
That night.
Okay.
And there's only one fucking Dan Marino that look like Dan Marino verse fucking
Dan Fouts way back in the day.
And those two guys,
I mean,
I'm not saying they want to eventually be there,
but like,
I can't imagine what Marino and Dan Fouts what had done to those in today's era.
You know,
they threw for four,
400 yards,
a fucking game,
three,
400 yards of fucking game back when you could actually cover a receiver.
Borderline beat the shit out of him as he's going down.
You could fuck up a quarterback,
you could sack a quarterback and then like,
actually they'd lose yardage rather than the team with the court of the offense.
You know,
getting a first down,
cause you tackled the guy too fucking hard.
I don't like it.
Okay.
It's fucking sissy football.
You know,
it just,
you know,
I get it,
I get it.
People get fucking hurt.
But,
uh,
I dunno,
just listen to those fucking announced is called [inaudible] is bored
and they're not even addressing the level that the game has changed
at whatever.
It's a fucking show.
It's God damn show.
And I'm an old man and I said what?
I said,
I'm just going to go to like,
I dunno,
I'm going to fucking start watching rugby or something.
Something with a guy with the ball is going to get fucking tackled.
I would love to do a podcast and interview some great defensive players and just
see what they're thinking about this shit.
Um,
and how they think that they would do.
It's changed that much.
But like I said,
there's always,
you know,
the older generation never likes the new,
the new shit,
but you got guys now who literally are still playing in the league tweeting
saying it's fucked up.
So I want to think that I'm right.
But whenever I talk like this,
I always,
there was an NFL films.
If anybody can find the clip,
please tweet it to me.
There was this guy,
you know,
he was this old school,
middle linebacker or something like that.
It's like back during the Sam House days.
And they asked him,
Hey,
what do you think about some of the kids playing football today?
And he just goes,
I wouldn't watch your football game.
Can you give your fee?
You almost fucking had a stroke.
So maybe I'm doing that,
but I just,
baseball is still fucking baseball man.
So you got,
you know,
still got to fucking hit it over the fence.
They got rid of the roids I think,
I don't know.
But like,
uh,
the NBA,
it's like nobody's allowed to stand underneath.
Even on defense.
You got to get the fuck out of there were just,
I dunno guys go when they start driving from the three point line and people
would just get the fuck out of them.
I love when the guy goes up to dunk and the guy thinks about blocking it and
he's like,
oh,
I don't end up on Instagram.
And he tries to kind of duck out of the picture and then the bench goes nuts and
they're waving towels at,
at a,
at an uncontested dunk
in my dunk.
Complaining.
I think I am.
Hey everybody.
The seventh annual Patrice O'Neal comedy benefit.
Uh,
tickets are going fast.
Thank you guys.
Thank you so much.
The lineup,
uh,
it's good to go.
Sorry.
It's gonna be Tuesday,
February 19th,
2019 at 7:00 PM at the city center theater,
one 31 west 55th street,
New York,
New York one double a one nine.
Uh,
the lineup is big.
Jay Oakerson,
Chris read safer sounds.
Gary Gulman,
Jim Gaffigan,
Michelle Wolf,
Rich Vos and yours truly,
uh,
with more names to be announced.
Um,
we're waiting for people's availabilities and that type of stuff.
Like,
you know,
obviously,
uh,
comics working for free,
giving up their free time so people are trying to work it out with their
schedules.
But,
uh,
just an overwhelming response.
Thank you guys.
So,
so much.
Like I said,
it's the best thing that I do all year.
It's been helping his family incredibly.
So thank you so much for that.
And with that,
the old ball,
the old freckles,
he ain't what it used to be.
Um,
I miss a lights out defense,
Huh?
That's all I'm saying.
Remember the fucking doom state defense against the steel curtain,
you know,
but no name defense.
The over the hill gang,
the sack exchange,
the 46 defense.
And how much fun was it to watch the fucking bears that year with Wilbur?
Gary Fensick,
Mike Singletary,
Richard Dent.
I mean they,
they were,
they were fucking unbelievable lights.
Fucking out defense.
I don't know why people don't like watching that.
You know,
a high got high powered offense against a great defense.
Watch that chest mass instead of having just like fucking
free for all.
I felt like I was watching somebody play like one of those bar games.
You know those people,
when they throw the basket,
the basket ball into the basket and those people get so good they can use
either,
either hand.
That's the way they were fucking scoring.
We get it built.
All right.
He likes everybody.
You have a wake up in the morning with regrets of what you done,
replaying the terrible decisions you made the previous night over and over and
over.
Just my inner voice,
the kicking,
sweating,
yelling or whatever else you did to piss everyone in the bedroom off.
Well,
guess what?
But deciding to sleep on a shitty mattress,
is your choice,
uh,
buying.
Okay,
but bill,
buying a mattress is so high and where would I begin?
There are literally writing this for me.
Um,
well you're in luck buddy,
because he likes sleep.
The mattress I've been yelling at you to buy for almost two years will change
your life.
Just go to hell.
sleep.com/bird take their two minutes sleep quiz and they'll match you to the
perfect mattress.
I can't even fucking,
how big do I have to make the print?
I'm one of those guys.
I'm never getting glasses.
I think glasses are for fucking weak people
or people that have,
are strong enough to admit that they have a problem.
I don't know where I am on that side of the fence.
I don't know if I'm a hero or if I'm a coward.
Um,
it's like Tinder for finding a mattress.
I just said in the larger,
all the fun with na,
uh,
with none of the next morning regrets and misery.
And right now you can get up to $125 off your mattress.
Order at Helix,
sleep.com/burr.
They have a 100 night trial,
free shipping and won't send you creepy next day texts.
That's,
that's helix,
sleep.com/birth for $125 off your mattress.
Helic sleep.com h e l I x sleep.com/.
Burn.
All right.
Hi,
I'm not getting glasses so I'm just going to wait someday when there's an
affordable robot,
I'll just have that cunt fucking read for me.
How vulnerable,
what will I be?
Yeah.
Did you see that?
Could you know,
cause the thing will be fucking smarter than I am.
Then I also,
I can't see how soon before that thing fucking brains meet with something in the
kitchen.
Do you guys see that commercial?
I think it's for sprint.
You know where that guy was sold out.
He used to be with Verizon,
you know,
and then they fired him and then he fucking,
he's like the Henry Hill of fucking wireless service.
He fucking,
you know,
he jumps over with sprint.
So they're doing this,
this thing with,
this lady's going to take a picture and she's just talking about how clear it is
and it's three people in a fucking robot for whatever reason.
And The lady is,
so the lady taking the picture is so fucking blown away by how clear the screen
is.
She just keeps commenting on it and she's not taking the picture and all the
people are smiling and going,
okay,
yeah,
it's great.
Great.
And so he goes,
I can't hold my smile much longer than the other guy goes.
I can't all my smile either.
And the robot goes,
I can,
yeah,
right there.
You see everything that just fucking happen in that commercial they made having
a robot seen fucking normal to the point you're taking a family fucking photo
with it in front of the Grand Canyon.
Okay,
okay.
And then the human beings are in in their own way or admitting that they're not,
they're not as good as the robot.
They're getting it in your fucking head,
that these things are,
are just normal and they should be in your fucking life and that you're not
worthy.
You know that fucking trader from Verizon,
if you wanted to redeem himself,
should have grabbed that fucking robot and throwing them right off the class.
All I'm saying,
it's how I liked that,
so I would've liked it to end,
but I know that that's,
that's in,
that's in a perfect world.
All right,
legal zoom,
everybody.
Um,
evidently this podcast is brought to you by legalzoom.com and the number four.
You know,
the saying time is money.
It's true,
especially when you run your own business.
But running a successful business involves taxes,
contracts,
hush money,
and a whole lot of fine print things that eat up too much of your time.
Well,
it's time to turn to legals zone.
Over the last 17 years,
more than a million Americans have used legal zoom to help launch their
business,
says businesses.
It is,
but that's only the beginning.
Legal Zoom has a network of independent attorneys.
These guys went rogue man.
They're independent and tax professionals who can provide you with advice.
You need to get through the daily grind of running your own business.
Uh,
and the best part is you don't have to worry about driving to anyone's office
are being billed by the hour.
Since legalzoom isn't a law firm,
okay,
I don't get another,
not a law for me.
You can take fucking legal advice from,
you can't count on legal.
You can count on legal zoom to provide the business resources you need and
services that fits into your schedule.
Invest your time and money into growing your business and let legal zoom help
with the legal stuff.
Go to legal zoom.com now and used to coat bar B,
u.
R.
I Yell,
I scream when they,
it's all in capitals.
I yell at Boro Checkout for special savings.
Once again,
that's Promo code back at legal,
zoom.com legal zoom where life meets legal.
You know,
they were proud of that.
Say we're life meets legal.
I liked it.
Alliteration.
It's quick.
It's succinct.
It's the sink too.
It's succulent.
Um,
anyways,
so,
uh,
I dunno what to name this podcast,
but I,
you know Billy,
it didn't have his cranberry juice.
Diddy.
Huh?
Well,
Bill,
he's been on the rag here about all the sports.
I just want a little bit of defense.
That's all built for fuck sakes.
Okay.
It's over.
No more defense.
You can't take your dick out of work and,
and uh,
I dunno what else?
And,
and it's called climate change.
I get it.
Things are changing.
I'm getting older.
Um,
anyway,
so I'm having some people over.
I invited all these fucking people to come over my house,
not realizing that the Osu fucking Michigan game is,
starts at 9:00 AM Pacific standard time.
So kinda changes the menu.
I guess there'll be making some breakfast burritos over there.
Uh,
Jesus Christ,
I hope fucking Michigan wins it this year.
They said that it has to become a rivalry again.
I wonder what they are all time.
I think Michigan had them and then,
and now they just diffed it.
Ohio state has gone on such a run.
I would say that they caught up and passed him.
O s you come on,
you can't.
O s u verse Michigan's.
Anybody watching that kid down there at Duke?
Jesus Christ that Manchild uh,
Osu,
verse Michigan.
Okay.
Record.
Here we go.
Maybe that's the one all time Michigan football rivalry.
Doodah Doodah all right,
let's see.
Early years,
the snow bowl will and woody Hayes,
God know something crazy happen.
Anytime I think I'm angry.
I just watched Woody Hayes highlights.
I'm like,
Hey,
you know,
I'm not that bad.
A dead fucking bad.
10 year war haze verse Sham Bo Schembechler.
Yeah.
Until Woody Hayes punched that guy in the fucking under the the job.
Remember that the kid intercepted the ball and what he got so fucking mad as a
kid on the,
the team he grabbed me,
he punched him.
You know,
the guy wanted to win Michigan verse Oh s you
all time head to head.
Year by year.
Maybe this will get it for me.
Come on man.
All Time results.
Here we go.
Okay.
Yeah.
Da Da da Da.
That,
uh,
that,
built,
that's the Notre Dame one.
I know they all sound the same to me.
Ah,
ah,
Bam,
Bam.
Eh?
All right.
Who gives a fuck about Wade in 1912?
All right,
let's,
let's just look over the last few years.
Alright.
Michigan is not one since 2011.
Yeah.
All right.
Oh,
well she was one,
one,
two,
three,
four,
five,
six years in a row.
Okay.
And they've won seven,
eight,
nine,
10,
11,
12,
13,
13 of the last 14 fucking years.
Jesus Christ.
MMM.
Wait a minute.
In 1998 Osu one,
get the fuck outta here.
Am I reading this right?
I'm not reading this right.
Am I?
Oh,
that's ranking.
How fucking difficult can this be?
Oh,
no,
no.
I'm Rena.
Right?
Okay.
Sorry.
Jesus Christ.
Do you guys still listening to this?
I don't know why people listen to this fucking podcast.
This has gotta be most unprofessional thing.
Ebo I,
and I thought I went in 1999 I went to Ohio state versus Michigan,
but Tom Brady played that game.
So I wasn't,
I went to the one in 1998
okay.
Was it 97 cause Michigan won the year.
I went and I go in [inaudible] 90 maybe [inaudible] 97
I don't fucking remember.
All right.
The 1990s Michigan,
Michigan.
It was a tie.
Michigan,
Ohio State,
Osu,
Michigan.
Decade before eighties starting in 1980 when Michigan,
Ohio state,
Ohio State,
Michigan,
Ohio state,
Michigan.
Let's see,
the 70s,
the 10 year war,
Ohio State,
Michigan,
Ohio state tie,
Ohio state,
Michigan,
Ohio.
State's so wait a second,
I have state went one,
two,
three,
four,
five Michigan,
one,
two,
three,
four.
Then the tie.
All right.
Did they have the all time?
So what does he all time?
Michigan dominated the early years compiling at 1201 to record in the non
conference matchup.
Uh,
Jesus Christ.
Look how small this fucking Prentice.
There's no fucking way.
All right.
Now I gotta find this fucking thing.
This is like to the point,
am I forgetting that I'm podcasting right now?
Whatever.
So you guys,
you know the fucking millennials,
she probably already to look this up 58 fucking times.
I don't know.
I don't know how to figure out.
Oh,
I took my daughter to Guitar Center for the first time,
the one on sunset boulevard,
the big one that they,
um,
they re did and it was hilarious.
So I took a picture of me and my daughter,
right.
You know,
with the Guitar Center logo behind us and she was reaching for the camera,
but look like she was doing the rock star point right at the camera.
And I'm sitting there cheese and smiling luck next to her.
So I look like I'm a fan of hers.
It's right now.
It's my favorite fucking a,
it's my favorite God damn a picture that I have over.
Uh,
by the way,
thank you to everybody that signed up to my,
for my patrion page.
Uh,
next week me and Joey roses,
the teen idol sensation from the opiate Anthony Program.
Um,
the late great opie and Anthony Program,
we'll be,
uh,
we'll be doing a couple more episodes of uninformed yelling at each other and
all that type of shit.
Uh,
I got the free time now and we fly the helicopter,
get some fucking video for you.
And we have exclusive footage from my show at Madison Square Garden.
Uh,
me doing the sound check
saying I was going to kill.
I knew it.
I knew it was going to kill one of those nights.
You just could feel it.
And then in the end,
uh,
Andrew fucking walked all the way around a meet Joe and verse.
You all sing goodnight.
It follows me all the way through the crowd,
all the way into the back green room.
And there was another big time comic there that I had no idea that they were
there,
captured that whole fucking conversation all.
So that's,
that's the direction my patriot on page is going to go.
It's to be a lot of personal shit like that.
Um,
that,
you know,
I don't mind putting out there for a few people.
Try not to do it for a bunch of fucking,
you know,
I feel like I'll let you in enough with death if I die.
All right?
That's the fucking podcast.
Enjoy the music.
And then there's going to be another half hour of,
um,
content from a Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday,
Monday morning podcasts from,
I dunno,
earlier this year or 10 years ago,
whenever the fuck I started doing these things,
uh,
I'm pulling from Michigan.
I respect Ohio state.
I just want it to be a rivalry again.
You know,
I'd like to see Jim Harbaugh,
you know,
at this point.
I mean,
what was the last time his wife had a good Christmas?
come on.
He,
the guy's got a win here.
Yeah.
I would think even,
even,
even when they do win,
you still gotta be like,
you know,
when he's around the house,
he's like,
Jimmy,
relax Kate.
Just,
you know,
it's breakfast.
You don't have to have some toast.
Where do I get off calling anybody else a fucking lunatic.
Oh,
you know what I love and went to the heart doctor and my heart looks great.
So right now my chest pains.
I know that's just fucking indigestion.
What would you do if I fucking killed over right now?
You know it is.
I eat too fast.
All right.
Now I want all you guys who aren't doctors out there right now to then tell me,
you know the dangers of fucking that.
What about this fucking jerk off?
Who goes to that Goddamn island in the middle of nowhere and gets his dumb ass
killed?
He fucking went there at one time.
He gets shot with a bunch of fucking arrows and then leave.
Then he fucking comes back again.
Only somebody like who's delusional with religion can be that fucking stupid.
Okay
to go over.
I mean,
what the fuck?
What the fuck are you doing?
Jesus Christ.
You know what I love too is everybody assumed it was a fucking white guy,
myself included.
Am I guess that's where you go.
That's what the fuck we do.
Hey,
don't go over there.
You could get killed.
Oh yeah.
Where is it?
Oh,
we go check it out.
I think the dude was Asian American.
I hate that he lost his life.
But I am psyched that for once somebody did some dumb white guy shit,
and it wasn't a dumb white guy.
All right,
dumb white guys finished in November Straw.
Um,
I always wonder what my neighbors think when I Yell Shit like that.
I can't tell if he's,
if he's gone crazy is his wife and trouble.
We don't know.
Oh,
by the way,
a massively positive feedback of Nia reading the questions.
So,
oh my God,
my fucking daughter gave me shit for the first time ever in front of everybody
to Thanksgiving at the Thanksgiving dinner table.
She's sitting there and she was being all whining,
everything,
you know,
demanding and all of this stuff.
I go,
good Lord.
what are you doing over there?
What do you,
are you the boss baby?
And she looks at me,
she goes,
you want to buff baby?
And the whole table was,
it was like,
when spider Gosia I,
I,
you go fuck yourself Tommy.
Everybody just went like,
oh shit.
And I was looking at Nia going like,
did she just say that?
Did she say you're the boss baby,
or she just mumbled something.
It's,
I know she can say boss,
baby,
but you went your buck baby.
It was just like,
Jesus,
God.
And now we've entered this chapter.
Um,
anyways.
All right.
That's it.
Everybody hope you had a lovely thanksgiving.
Uh,
don't be afraid to go for a walk,
man.
Go for a walk and have some fruit and vegetables.
You don't have to fucking do that much damage this weekend.
He could still enjoy yourself,
but you know,
be,
don't be a fucking jerk.
All right.
Um,
I don't know what that meant.
Either.
Have a great weekend.
You constant.
I'll check.
I'll see you on Monday.
Uh,
be yourself,
Eh,
eva it.
If you're a vegetarian,
Ooh,
say dose.
Still figured dad fucking
but don't be a Douche and say I can't eat the stuffing because it was in the
[inaudible] Berber
friends.
We hear it.
The Monday morning podcast.
Want to extend
a very happy and healthy thanksgiving.
Wished to each and every one of you.
And we would also like it if you took time to think of those who are a little
less fortunate.
That's the only fucking thing I hate about this holiday,
right?
This is such a great fucking holiday in that there's no corporate bullshit,
They can't get you.
You don't,
you can't,
you don't have to go out and go buy anybody anything.
Everybody just makes something to eat.
You go over somebody's house and you fucking throw down and I don't know how,
but for some reason this unbelievable holiday has,
has remained like corporate free.
Like they can't figure out how the fuck to get you to buy something on a day
when it's all about feeding your fucking face other than food,
obviously.
But you know what I mean?
They haven't figured out a way to be like,
is this the year you stick the ring and the yams
buy her a car on Thanksgiving?
You know,
God knows that would be all about the fucking broads,
right?
The fuck are you going to get hurt?
Some sort of,
what are you gonna get high?
One of the,
one of those,
one of those buzzer rings on and make your friends laugh around on the water
bubbler that stunk.
That was a bad example.
You know why?
Cause I have no fucking example.
Because basically when you're a man,
you stop getting good gifts past the age of 12 once you're too old for toys,
that's it.
You get close.
You get bullshit,
right?
The fucking broad sit down.
Hey,
what?
This shiny thing that car and cause six weeks a year pay.
Really?
What are you take this fucking piece of coal.
Stick it up.
Your Hoo Ha.
And see what happens at six weeks.
If it's shiny sticker on your finger,
if it hasn't shut it,
you fuss ticket your fucking pile.
That's what I'm trying to say.
Sorry.
This is supposed to be about giving thanks now.
So I love this fucking holiday.
You know,
I like to eat.
Hey,
who doesn't?
Right?
But every time they have to still fucking ruined it.
One of these ds network Douche bags during the Macy's Day parade,
when they sit sitting there with their network,
ear muffs and gloves on,
right with the fucking McGraff trench coat,
they always have to say,
you know,
Thanksgiving's that's a lie.
That's what Tammy gear and blah blah,
blah,
all this shit you're ready to throw down.
And then they got to go at the last second be like,
but what about Haiti?
And then they get a show,
a bunch of fucking earthquake victims are still trapped under a swing set.
You know,
it's like,
can you just,
can I just have one holiday off?
Can I do that?
So I'm not,
what all I'm doing to do is I'm going to watch the fucking football.
Did that makes sense?
Um,
anyways,
Hey,
am I the only guy who gets creeped out by that fucking eight legged Turkey John
Madden has every year?
Did he stop doing that because he's retired now?
I,
there was always something a little wrong about that or,
well,
maybe there was a little bit of foreshadowing of what manmade turkeys are gonna
look like in a few years.
Right.
I mean they already do that with,
with the chickens don't die.
People lock what?
Meat,
right?
So they gave him fucking steroids and now they can't even walk cause they're pex
a tipping them over.
Do you guys see Food Inc?
It's just see that,
oh God,
this podcast started off with such promise.
I don't even know where I am and it right now.
Um,
anyway,
so this is the Monday morning podcast for Monday.
Here we go.
Let's get back to some familiar ground here.
Let's get back to what I say every week.
Uh,
for Monday,
November 22nd.
Wait a minute.
November 22nd,
this is a,
an important day in the history of America.
This is a,
what is this?
This is the 1963.
This is the 47th anniversary of the whacking of President John F.
Kennedy,
right?
Cause he was the first guy who started printing money outside the Federal
Reserve,
printed out some fucking coins and they weren't having that shit.
So they fucking whacked him in Dallas.
And then to send a message to every fucking president who came after him.
They put his head on the fucking silver dollar,
you know,
not in honor of him.
That's the Federal Reserve's way.
It's like when you shoot a deer and you put its head on the wall,
that's what the Federal Reserve does.
When you fuck with them,
they blow your brains out and then they stick your head on a coin,
you know?
But if you play by the fucking rules,
they stick you on some paper.
That's how it works.
That's my theory.
And I'm,
I'm going with that.
Yeah.
47 years ago to this day,
and they haven't changed anything in Dealey Plaza in Dallas.
If you ever go there and you want to see the creepiest tourist attraction of all
time,
they have not even changed a post office box.
You walk there,
it's like stepping back in time.
You can walk around with audio.
I know I've talked about this before,
but for,
uh,
for uh,
all the mates over there and fucking England down in Australia,
where else?
Where else do I have to give shout outs to Ireland?
Scotland,
Sweden,
all the places I've played over there.
I'm actually,
it was actually talking to my booker,
uh,
my booking agent.
Um,
last week I'm putting together another Europe run for 2011 or write you fucking
cunts.
Uh,
going to be another London,
Dublin,
Glasgow,
Stockholm,
Sweden.
Maybe I can do a Scandinavian run over there.
You know,
how great is my fucking life.
All right.
And for all you European outcasts down under,
uh,
we're also working on Australia and I know I promised yours coming there in the
fall.
I don't know what the fuck happened,
but
what are you going to do?
You know,
if you guys have plenty to do down there,
right.
Ac DC,
uh,
that go through the phone with those people.
Nicole Kidman and are angry forehead in a Justin Bieber,
Justin Bieber,
Justin Bieber is arguably the biggest star to come out of Australia.
Said,
uh,
said set.
Go through the phone that I can never remember his fucking name.
Michael stray hand by the way was the football player is trying to remember.
And,
uh,
just to be a cunt.
I said Justin Bieber was from Australia and if you actually got upset and
started screaming at whatever the fuck you're listening to this podcast on right
now,
and you actually know where the fuck the persons from,
you know,
what does that say about you?
You know,
I'm sick of them talking about the Justin Bieber haircut.
Mick Jagger had that fucking haircut on the fucking Ed Sullivan Shell,
you know,
back then when he wore ties.
All right,
what the fuck is going on here?
My brain right now is thinking about making up like fucking diff,
12 different categories so I don't have to talk about the same shit.
It's getting a little stale.
It's getting a little stale for me.
Um,
yeah,
that's how I wanted to talk about.
Let's talk about fucking a front men in rock music.
The Best Front men of all time.
Recently I've gone on this,
this insane rolling stone old school kick where,
uh,
I finally downloaded,
get your,
yeah.
Yeahs out there live concert from a Madison Square Gardens.
Fucking unbelievable.
Then I was on the road when I was in Columbus and I bought another one just
called ladies and gentlemen,
the rolling stones and they're playing somewhere in Texas.
It's just fucking unreal how unbelievable those guys are as a live band.
And I was watching Mick Jagger and I started thinking,
because I always left him out of the equation when I was thinking,
you know,
best front men of all time and I might have to give it to him.
All right?
You know,
I always argue Brady,
Peyton Manning,
I think you know,
who do you,
who you like better,
you like a Freddie Mercury or Mick Jagger.
Uh,
Freddie Mercury is fucking unbelievable as far as how that dude seriously turned
Wembley Stadium into like a coffee house and had like it just a single long,
just him and the crowd,
not even the fucking band.
He's like sitting down and chilling out.
Like he's,
he's like,
he's in,
in his fucking living room,
I think as far as charisma and power of voice and just the ability to be five
foot one,
102 pounds and strut around the fucking stage.
And have everybody captivated.
I Dunno if you can beat Freddie Mercury,
but,
uh,
if anybody can,
I,
I would,
I would put Mick Jagger right up there,
go watch some of his live shit.
He sees fucking ridiculous.
How,
how,
what an amazing front man that guys,
he did rip off some shit.
I saw him when he was,
um,
what does that song,
uh,
the midnight Rambler,
you know,
and you know,
the whole breakdown part where he's like,
well,
hey,
have you heard about the,
did black?
All right,
well he dropped to his knees milking the moment,
which anybody who's watched music knows he stole that from James Brown.
And he also was doing some,
his version,
his fucking English version,
you know,
have those,
those little fucking,
you know,
the James Brown thing where you fucking,
somehow your feet aren't moving,
but they are moving,
but you're not taking steps and you go inside,
decided he steals a little bit of that.
Uh,
but as far as white dudes go,
you know what I mean?
Uh,
I though those would be my top two and,
uh,
I would listen to either either side of those arguments.
So I bring them on.
I want to hear what you have to gut w what you have to say.
David Lee Roth,
you know,
as far as like heavy metal goes,
how do you find a guy,
you know,
Robert Plant,
although I gotta say Robert Plant,
you know,
the old thing that knocks him down a little bit is a,
when he wasn't stealing lyrics from old blues guys,
he was singing about dungeons and dragons before it came out.
So his shit,
I dunno if it,
uh,
if it holds,
did this certain certain bands,
it's weird like the music holds up,
but sometimes the lyrics,
like I was listening to some old Metallica the other day and his fucking awesome
as they are,
some of their old lyrics really has a Keanu Reeves,
you know,
flavor to it.
You know,
the thing that shouldn't be,
whoa,
what's,
what does it seek and destroy?
It's all destruction.
It sounds like a 12 year old wrote it.
Am I really criticizing Metallica on a week when I should be giving thanks that
those guys fucking blew my eardrums out for 30 fucking years.
I'm sorry.
You know what?
This is my deal.
I figured out the other day,
I have taken 24 flights,
24 different flights.
This is the life of a touring comedian since the beginning of October.
I basically,
let's see,
I flew from La to Boston,
Boston to Minneapolis,
Minneapolis to Chicago,
Chicago to La.
Then I flew la to Chicago,
Chicago to Albany,
drove to buffalo and then I went buffalo,
Chicago's Chicago,
la.
I've already lost count.
How many of those are La to St Louis?
St Louis,
La La to Dallas.
Dallas to Columbus.
Columbus to Dallas.
Dallas to La.
Where,
what the fuck did I go after that?
Oh,
in between there a fucking La to New York,
New York,
back to La
and then this past weekend I went fucking La to Newark,
New Jersey.
Drove to Pennsylvania,
did a college Gig,
drove back to New York,
picked up Joe to Rosehill over there,
drove down to DC,
did a gig down there,
went to the airport,
got on a fucking puddle jumper,
flew to Hartford,
gotten a rent a car and drove out to Fox woods.
Did a Gig there,
drove from Foxwoods back down in Newark,
got on a fucking plane and flew all the way to la.
I've done all of that since the first weekend
in New York.
And would you believe it?
I threw my fucking backout.
That's what ends up happening when you fly on planes and shit.
You just sitting there like you're on fucking punishment.
And I fucked up my,
I don't know,
my back got tight and the other day I,
I,
uh,
I throw out my back and it's still fucked up.
I don't what the hell to do about it,
you know,
not only do I not know what to do about my back,
I don't know what to do about this podcast right now cause I don't know what
happened.
It was starting off great.
I sang you a little fucking song.
I put an echo effect on it.
Um,
you know what?
Let's,
let's talk a,
let's talk a little fucking NFL football.
I didn't watch any NFL football yesterday because I was traveling.
I missed it all.
I did sit down and I watched the Patriots,
the Patriots game,
and a lot of people sent me emails and they were anticipating that I was going
to trash Peyton manning.
All right?
And I think it's time.
I have to,
I have to two,
two fucking reemphasized my mission statement.
All right.
Somewhere in all this shit defending Tom Brady,
people think that I hate Peyton manning the same way.
People really think that I fucking hate the jets.
I'm going to get to both of those.
All right.
Peyton Manning,
the Shit I gave him was how they were calling him the greatest QB of all time.
That's where I give him shit.
I give him shit about that and I give him shit about his performance,
his playoff record.
That's what I do.
But I don't think he sucks as a quarterback.
I just take offense when somebody says that he's the greatest quarterback of all
time.
And that Tom Brady always takes a fucking back seat to them.
That's what I don't like.
Despite Tom Brady's playoff record.
Tom Brady's winning percentage is right there with Peyton manning.
He's,
he does better in the fucking playoffs and they're head to head match ups.
he's fucking killing the guy.
So,
but I,
you know,
I still understand that pate and puts up these monster numbers.
But how about every once in a while you have a debate about Tom Brady and Peyton
manning and it's sort of like maybe six people like Peyton,
seven people like Tom Brady,
just,
you know,
50,
50 maybe tips,
Tom Brady's way every fucking once in a while just doesn't happen.
So yesterday the Patriots beat the colts or hung on to beat the colts,
which is why I'm not going to talk shit.
All right.
Unlike these fucking jets fans who keep winning in the last seconds against
fucking,
you know,
teams that aren't gonna make the playoffs.
Um,
you know,
and then they start sending me emails,
like they just want to play off game,
which I really don't understand,
which I kind of get because they don't do well in the playoffs for my entire
life.
So I guess these are victories,
so I guess that's why you talk shit.
I have no fucking idea.
But you know,
Peyton manning yesterday,
it's not like we beat the colts,
you know,
that's not the fucking Marvin Harris,
Reggie Wayne,
Dallas Clark and all those guys.
You know what I mean?
I know Reggie Wayne play,
but come on,
it's like they're,
they have a ton of injuries and that defense sucks.
All right.
But on the other side of the ball,
uh,
we have two rookie titans that are,
our offense seems to be built around and we were starting like three,
four rookies on defense.
So we're both sort of a,
it's weird.
I think both of those teams and their records are a testament to how fucking
good both of those quarterbacks are.
And certainly with the Patriots.
What a great coach Bill Belicheck is.
All right.
All you fucking [inaudible] who keep telling me,
you know,
keep trash and bill Belicheck you know these guys are still given me shit on the
Internet about that spy gate fucking horse shit.
Let me see if I can put this thing to bed.
First of all,
man.
Genie man,
genius as the jets call them jet fans.
Of course San Shies man genius Richard Todd's the next Joe Nemeth.
You know they do that shit down there,
right?
Um,
he,
he coached with the Patriots.
So evidently if bill,
if Bill Bella check was doing that all the time,
he built his fucking resume and he has a job right now in head coaching because
of that spygate shit.
And then he turns around and rats out.
Bill Bellacheck and then I've also told all you've cuts out there that bill
Belicheck is not the only guy who does that shit.
They send out a league wide memo telling everyone to stop doing it.
And if you don't believe me,
if you don't believe me,
that everybody does it.
Watch when head coaches talk to each other on the sidelines on Nfl Sunday.
Do you notice that they put their hands up over their mouth or they take their,
their fucking,
you know that little,
yeah,
that sheet that they have all their plays on and they put it up over there
fucking mouth.
They put their hand up over their mouth like fucking a Joe Pesci in casino when
they're out there in the parking lot.
Why do you think that is?
All you guys who are trying to blame that fucking epidemic of a crime on one
guy.
Why do you think they do that?
Do you think it's because they have bad breath?
You fucking morons.
It's because not only does everybody do it,
they're still doing it.
You just can't do it from the sidelines.
They got people up in the booth by not oculars.
They got fun.
I bet they got people in the crowd with cameras was zoom lenses.
This millions of dollars at stake.
This egos,
it's fake.
All right.
I just love how people,
okay.
People who can do fucking roids take HGH.
They're going to fucking cheat when,
when the fucking refs aren't going to look,
but you know,
they're not going to still continue to,
to,
to videotape.
Would that technology exists?
Give me a fucking break.
All right.
And if any of you comes out there,
who always bitched says that Bella Cheat Shit.
If you can explain to me why they're covering up their fucking their hand over
their mouth.
And if one of you dumb fucks,
tries to tell me that someone on the other sideline with the naked eye can look
through 22 players and read the lips of somebody.
I am going to find out where you live through uh,
something,
something.com and I'm going to slap you with this fucking microphone.
All right?
So there you go.
I actually,
I can't believe him.
It says,
I actually felt bad for pate Manny.
Uh,
that game.
He played a great fucking game.
He did all the fucking work.
Okay.
I can't talk shit.
That game was tied up.
Okay.
Vietnam voluntary comes and kicks the fucking field goal.
All right?
This isn't like last year where he had all his fucking weapons.
It was the Joe Montana moment and the reason why I trashed him,
because they were already handing him the crown as the greatest quarterback of
all fucking time before he'd even won his second ring.
So I felt vindicated.
So I actually felt bad for the guy when he's running off the fucking field.
Uh,
and believe me,
I couldn't believe it,
but I actually did.
I was like,
Eh,
you know,
guy played a great fucking game.
You know,
he,
he doesn't have any of his weapons.
He still hung in there and uh,
you know,
and I can't talk shit about the Patriots because our defense is,
is it's just,
I mean,
it's,
it's aged me 30 years.
I just watched the replay of the game and I'm so fucking glad I wasn't watching
that live.
Uh,
were great.
First down and second down,
but third down,
huge.
Jesus Christ.
It's a,
we're still a,
you know,
I would say two years away,
but because we have bill Belicheck,
I would say we're still a year away,
but I just don't see us going deep into the playoffs with that fucking defense.
And,
um,
and I still don't think we match up well against the jets because they have,
they have a really,
really good defense.
So I think that can neutralize our offense.
And then they go out there,
they have a great offensive line and
Sanchez has too much fucking time.
I don't know.
I,
but I,
I don't,
I don't see them kicking the shit out of us.
I mean,
we could obviously still win that game in New England,
but,
um,
which I actually have a feeling we're going to because that's just how things
kind of seemed to work out in the NFL.
But like,
you know,
I don't know.
I honestly,
I honestly can't talk shit about that game.
It was a fucking awesome game.
And,
uh,
and I got admitted.
It was a little sad watching Brady and Peyton manning with,
with teams that weren't as good as back in the fucking day,
you know,
but I,
I'm hoping that they're both coming around because a,
it's a fucking great match up.
There you go.
Look at that.
Look at me the week of thanksgiving,
not being a cunt.
And uh,
let's see here.
I have some reason I have the jets down here.
The jets,
somebody said a bill in two weeks we beat,
oh,
okay.
Here we go.
It says bill,
in two weeks we beat two of the best NFL teams,
the Steelers and the colts.
Uh,
see that's another thing.
I,
the cults aren't one of the best teams.
They,
they have one of the best quarterbacks.
And you're thinking about cults,
teams of the past.
You can't see them say they're one of the best teams when all their guys are
hurt,
you know.
But anyways,
he says,
I think that is nothing compared to the,
but however,
I think that's nothing compared to the accomplishments of the New York jets.
I praise Rex Ryan,
Mark Sanchez and the whole jet organization for continuing to barely be able to
beat under 500 teams.
I mean the lions,
the browns and now the Texans.
Why even wait might as well build the Mark Sanchez statue right now.
Fuck the jets.
Um,
yeah.
And there's another way I can't talk shit cause the browns raped us.
So,
uh,
this is the thing,
I've been breaking the jets balls about winning last second every fucking week.
But you know,
once you do it six weeks in a row,
I mean you can't ignore that.
That does say something about your fucking team.
So,
uh,
and after last week when I went one in three with my gambling,
you know,
and I couldn't pick a fucking winner.
Um,
I got to admit,
man,
this,
this year has been really a,
it's kind of fucking awesome,
but it's really hard as a gambler trying to pick,
you know,
like what team is just going to step out and just be the fucking team,
I mean jet fans for as much as you guys keep winning.
I mean how much you agent down there and fucking New Jersey with the Jersey jets
there.
Huh?
It's fucking gotta be brutal for you every week.
But uh,
this week I actually,
I've gone to and one and a,
I have to bring this up here,
Paul Versey and I want you guys to give him shit too on his Facebook page.
Don't be overly mean.
Just actually,
you know what?
You would really be funny if you guys all just sent him letters of condolences
and you just hope that he's doing all right.
And if he needs anything,
you're there for him.
Just,
just go with that angle.
Um,
because he did the unthinkable,
the unprecedented last week.
Okay.
We,
we picked four games each week against the spread and against,
I don't know how,
how many odds and I,
how many odds were stacked up against this man.
But Paul Versey
when,
oh,
in four last week,
he fucking would have been better off if you blindfolded him,
spun him around three times and gave my handful of darts and there was teams
written on the wall and it just said,
start throwing.
I broke his balls a little bit.
I was like,
Jesus Christ,
I don't even think Nia could do that.
Oh,
so if you have time,
go to Paul Versey on Facebook via our Z.
I don't be a con because it's the week of thanksgiving.
Just just send him letters of condolences.
Just Act.
Treat him as though a family member just passed,
you know,
or maybe like a family pet,
not a young family member.
Like you know,
somebody like I like a grandfather that lived,
you know,
it was 97 and died,
you know those weird things where it's like,
you know,
you guys,
hello,
I'm so sorry for your loss,
but you know the fuck you lived to be 97,
the lucky son of a bitch.
Um Oh in fucking four.
I mean,
I almost did it last week,
one in three.
But that's the thing about going,
oh,
and for,
I mean it's,
it's like going Oh and 16 in the NFL.
Somebody,
somebody is going to come around and do you a favor.
Right?
So tonight,
the last game I have,
this is just like that Seahawks game last week when I picked Arizona and the
second I picked Arizona,
I'm like,
no dude,
pick the Seahawks.
And I was like,
no,
stick with your first choice for some stupid fucking reason.
I took Denver and the points tonight and uh,
I just really can see Philip Rivers coming out there with a fucking vengeance,
you know?
Oh,
I got to give a shout out to one of my listeners who I didn't even see the
email,
but he gave me five pics for this week and he went for and one against the
spread.
So a hats off to you,
sir.
You are a,
you're a better man than me.
Um,
all right,
let's move on here.
Let's get on with the,
uh,
oh my drinking.
People are asking me about my drinking or the lack thereof.
Uh,
yes.
This is my 37th day of sobriety.
I got this shit down.
I got it down.
I've gone to who I'm,
I'm easily going to make it to the rose bowl because I've already,
I've already gone through my tough drink in towns.
I went to DC,
I went through New York,
I worked with Joe to Rosa,
Chicago,
Minneapolis.
What the fuck else are you going to do up there?
MMM.
Oh,
by the way,
I,
so I saw that show man versus food and that was a show that I used to make fun
of.
I thought it was fucking stupid.
And uh,
it's just like,
Eh,
this is dumb.
I don't know.
Watch this fucking sweaty guy,
eat all this God damn food.
And I don't what happened.
I was on the road and I watched him,
I don't know where he was,
but he fucking,
uh,
he,
he ate this sandwich was a hit,
eat a Turkey sandwich that I swear to God was the size of a purse who stack that
fucking high.
It was ridiculous.
And then it came with a shake that you could literally put,
you could like,
you know,
people who like have like a,
like a tree growing in their house,
you know,
big that fucking pot is that,
that that was all,
it was four pounds of milkshake.
So the dude eats all but two bites of the Turkey Sandwich.
He sucks down this shake that looked like Yo,
you fucking was it as big as a fire hydrant,
worth the fucking milkshake.
He sucks his whole fucking thing down.
He's got 20 minutes to go to eat the final two fucking bites.
And he's just sitting there with like,
you know,
like the thinker,
you know that pose,
that great statute.
He's sitting there like that except he sweating and it took him 17 minutes to
eat two bites.
I mean,
I could've stuck both bites in my mouth and an I'm in like 30 seconds.
That's how fucking full this guy was and how hard he had to concentrate to not
just fucking blow Chow right after he fuck upload Chow.
Jesus Christ.
That's from my high school days.
Dog Hair about Eddie yabbies drank any fucking blue chow last night kid.
Um,
try and not to fucking puke.
But anyways,
he went to uh,
he went to Minneapolis and uh,
he,
there was some sort of sandwich up there that two places claim.
What the fuck was the sandwich to places claim that they are the original.
Could somebody please tell me what that place is,
what the name of that place is?
I want to fucking go there is,
I want to try that sound cause it looked delicious and for that matter if you
see a,
a city that I'm going to from coming to your city and there's that fucking place
where you got to go.
Like when I went to buffalo and they had anchor bar and a was it Duffy's or
something like that,
like those are the two places to get,
you know they basically invented buffalo wings.
If you know of any of those places,
please let me know because I'm really running out of fucking sporting events to
go to,
you know,
unless I want to start to go into like,
little league games and stand there like a fucking pervert.
I'll just show up with those black frame glasses standing,
you know,
close enough to the field,
but just far enough away from the rest of the crowd,
you know,
all by myself,
just looking like a fucking creep.
Um,
please let me know this because I've got to tell you,
you know,
I'm having a fucking,
I'm having more goddamn fun on the road right now.
I'm just meeting a lot of,
you know,
I'm finally getting to do some theaters.
Uh,
I'm having great shows.
I know,
I feel like I got my new hour is starting to get solid and uh,
I dunno,
I'm not boozing so I'm kind of doing other shit,
checking out some restaurants and whatnot.
So if you know of the,
some of those places,
please let me know.
All right.
And with that,
let's get on with the drinking question.
Uh,
hey bill.
So now that you have 30 plus days,
37,
30 plus days without any booze in you,
what are the pros and cons?
I remember when you were going,
when you were on the wagon earlier this year,
you said something to the effect of it being a little boring and you remembered
every second of every day.
I'm really interested to hear what the pros are in your opinion.
Uh,
do you feel more energetic,
clear-minded et cetera.
By the way,
are you a little squeamish to about Frankenstein man?
What Frankenstein manning is going to do to the pet secondary tomorrow go pets.
Yeah.
See,
yeah,
true.
Patriot fans were fucking nervous.
Uh,
yeah,
I was,
I was nervous.
Um,
the only thing I was counting on was the fact that he wasn't coming in with the
Colt team that you are used to.
But anyways,
back to the drinking questions.
Uh,
what are the pros and cons?
All right,
let's go with the cons first.
Cause those are funnier.
The cons are,
uh,
you know what the hardest part about not drinking is,
is you,
you,
you'll never realize how much you are bombarded with beer commercials until you
stopped drinking.
And it's not the dumb beer commercials.
You know,
the ones like the corona ones where it's the battle of the sexes or those ones
where they,
you know,
they're just trying to be funny where they just like a,
yeah.
You know,
why don't you order a real beer?
Well,
you know,
when you take your skirt off for whatever,
those are just silly.
Or those fucking Budweiser frogs and lizards back in the day,
those ones don't make you want to drink.
But those ones where they talk about the clean,
refreshing,
you know,
and they,
without those fucking Sam Adams commercials with the guy with the beard is
bearing his face into all those hops.
And then they just did just pour in the fucking beer into that perfect beer
glass.
Those are the ones where I start fucking,
you know,
I start getting all clammy,
like,
uh,
you know,
and it's weird when you're not drinking because if I'm drinking,
I see one of those,
I'll just,
I'll either not even notice it or I'll just be like,
God damn,
I want a beer and I'll go get one.
But when I'm going cold Turkey,
when I see those commercials,
I'm like,
God damn,
I would like about 56 of those right about now.
I would like to man versus booze.
Oh fuck.
There's a youtube video.
Don't do it.
I don't condone it.
But if you do it,
I'm gonna Watch it.
The health risks are unbelievably dangerous.
Do not do that.
Do not.
You cannot do man versus boost.
Somebody's going to fucking die.
Uh,
which is why they don't have any of those challenges in a bar.
So strike all of that.
Do not do that.
But that's,
that's what those beer commercials make me want to do,
man versus booze.
And it makes me want to sit there and,
uh,
oh God.
How about a fun challenge that would be,
can you imagine if you had like,
you don't you like those,
uh,
this how much I want to drink right now.
You know,
you know those,
those refrigerators that you,
that people keep wine bottles in,
wine,
fridges,
refrigerated wine things,
so fucking stupid.
Whatever the fuck you call those things.
You know what they had the glass door so he can see,
you can see the bottles chilling in there.
Imagine if you had a fucking ceiling to floor,
just like a refrigerator that had a glass door and behind it you just saw a
bunch of frosty fucking bottles of beer,
you know,
in,
on,
in.
The other one was just a bunch of frosty fucking awesome looking beard glasses.
Right.
And you at,
you had to kill them all.
Even if he couldn't fucking do it.
The pneumonic,
God damn fun that would be,
see,
this is why I'm never going to make it.
I'm not,
I'm not going to go my whole life
because uh,
you know what?
I think I might do that with Derosa when I eventually get off the wagon,
we might do man versus boots.
What is wrong with me?
See this,
this is the cons of going just totally cold Turkey is you start having
fantasies.
Like I just got lost in that Jesus Christ and then I was thinking like,
yeah,
we'll do what?
We'll fucking take a vacation.
You will have a fucking house on a lake like this.
How homoerotic fucking beer fantasy with Joe to Rosa.
The fuck is wrong with me.
That's what I was literally thinking.
You know?
Cause when you do something like that,
you want to make sure you got no place else to go.
Okay.
That's one of the cons.
You start fantasizing about booze so much.
You actually put yourself in such a semi gay situation with one of your best
friends.
Ah,
God damn it.
One of the things I love most about Joe to Rosa is he's a complete fuck up.
That's what I love about it.
You know,
there's nothing better than hanging out with a fuckup is is because you know it.
There's no pressure for you to get your shit together.
It's like when you hang out with a do gooder gooder,
it's a constant reminder of,
of,
of how awful you are as a person and how shitty your living your life.
But when you get hang out with a guy like Joe to Rosa,
you know,
he's smart about it.
He gets his work done,
he finishes writing the script,
he does his shows,
but afterwards he's old school.
He really is.
He's like Dean Martin without the charisma and the good looks.
Um,
anyways,
why am I trashed?
And Joe on Thanksgiving,
it's a week to give thanks.
I give thanks to that.
You know that Joe to Rosa and for years us Comedians have always trashed Joseph
Joe to Rosa talking about how he doesn't have any shoulders and I have
maintained for a good two and a half years I've been screaming,
I've been telling to,
to,
to people with def yelling at deaf ears,
what's that fucking expression,
whatever.
I'm talking to people and not listen to me.
Joe Derosa does not lack shoulders.
He has shoulders.
But what he doesn't have is that those two chunks of flesh,
you know,
the chunk of flesh on either side of your neck,
uh,
either,
yeah,
between your neck and your shoulder.
That that meat right there,
the trap Pz Muscle.
Is that what it is?
He doesn't have that.
He doesn't have collarbones that's what happened.
His collarbones never grew while the rest of his skeletal system grew.
His collarbones didn't.
So,
uh,
hence there was no need to put flesh in there.
So Joe is a head,
he's a neck and on either side of his neck,
he had his ball and socket joints for his shoulders are right where those,
those rivets were on the side of Frankenstein's next nec,
next plural idiot.
All right,
let's plow ahead here.
36 minutes in.
So those are the cons as you start fantasizing about booze and a,
for me anyways,
I can't speak for anybody else,
but it just makes you want to drink like 90 fucking beers like that.
There's a bar,
there's a German bar on the upper east side.
And this time when not when I go off the wagon,
this is where I want to go.
They have this insane,
I can't remember if it's a boot or if it's one of those things,
those beer glasses that looks like a giant fucking bond.
Um,
you know,
like I,
that's what I wanna drink.
I wanna drink one of those or just one of those giant mugs of fucking beer.
That's the con right now,
because as great as I feel,
that's what I think of in my head when I think about drinking everyday.
The glass gets bigger.
Frostier and uh,
Jesus,
I'm gonna,
I'm gonna start drinking halfway through this podcast if I keep talking about
it.
All right.
Uh,
what are the pros weight loss specifically in your face?
It,
you,
you face tightens up.
It's great.
You get your jaw line back.
Uh,
when some drunk whore comes up to you with fucking cigarettes and wine breath,
you see her for what she is.
All right.
You don't hang out with people after the show.
They get all drunk and fucking loud.
And what you end up,
you're standing there and what you really start hearing is these cliched
conversations that you have participated in for the last 25 fucking years of
your life.
You know,
you stand back and you get to watch people slowly lose control of their,
uh,
their judgment.
Um,
and you start to see people say things and do things that they're going to
apologize,
the regret for regret for or regret the next day.
Um,
what else?
Uh,
it starts to make you look at where you are and your life,
you know?
And uh,
I don't know if you're going to do something that's sort of scummy,
you have to do it stone sober.
And I think a lot of times when I do dirt bags,
Shit,
you know,
or I just do dumb shit.
I think it's because I'm drunk and I think that's why I'm drinking.
He's cause I'm shouting down that voice in my head that's telling me,
bill,
go to bed right now.
Just go to bed,
read,
you know,
finish that script.
That's another thing too was I started drinking.
When I start thinking of the sketch I was going to write or something like that
and I haven't done it.
And I'm like,
Oh,
I'm going to do it tomorrow.
And I start thinking,
you know,
the successful guys would be at going back to the hotel room right now and
they'd be finishing it,
right.
Take out a little fucking feathered,
you know,
stick it in that inkwell and they would finish writing it out.
But not,
you hear you.
Are you sitting here talking to these fucking people about football from the
1970s?
So,
um,
this plenty of pros about it.
You know,
I think if you're in a fucked up relationship and you sober up,
that'll help you,
you know,
I think,
uh,
I think a lot of people kind of use booze as a way to sort of medicate their way
through the year,
you know,
and not address shit that's really pissing them off and stuff.
I don't know.
Makes you want to work out.
It makes you want to change other stuff in your life where,
uh,
and actually go out and do things.
Another thing to see,
now I'm talking about going to cities.
I want to go to cool places to eat and that type of stuff and uh,
rather than,
you know,
where are the bars at?
So I can do what I've already done for the last 25 fucking years.
So there you go.
Those are the pros.
Um,
I'm not saying you've got to quit it for good unless you're a full on alcoholic.
Obviously I would quit it for good,
but if,
uh,
you know,
if he just getting that big Ted Kennedy had,
it's great to take a fucking month off.
You know?
I don't know.
That's it.
I don't know about you guys,
but I've just been boring the living shit out of myself this week.
All right,
let's get to underrated.
Overrated.
All right,
this is,
this is going to cause some fucking emails.
All right.
Overrated.
Reverse racism.
I love how white men tell minorities to quit whining about how unfair things
are,
but the second day become victims of racism.
All you hear is,
I can't insert complaint because I'm white.
Uh,
take some of your own advice.
Take some of your own advice.
You fucking hypocrite.
Could I have butchered that anymore?
Let me go back and read that.
Reverse racism.
I love how white men tell minorities to quit whining about how unfair things
are.
But the second they become victims of racism,
all you hear is,
I can't insert complaint because I'm white.
Take some of your own advice.
You fucking hypocrite.
There's the reed.
I fucking love that one.
I 100% agree with that one.
I,
it's embarrassing when I hear white guys,
specifically white guys,
you know,
white women still complained because that's what women do have all colors.
They just fucking bitch.
They're going to bitch about something.
You know,
take them to the restaurant that they've always wanted to go to.
You take them there and what happens?
Why do we have this thing over here?
Right?
Bitch about the table.
It's cold.
I like it,
but it's cold.
Do you have the fucking Blah,
blah,
blah?
Do you have that special?
And they take it off the menu,
that and then they pout.
And what do you want to do?
You,
you want to fucking take the check when it comes and stuff it down the back of
their throat.
Like that creepy moth that Hannibal lectors or that have that one fucking dude
you sit through and in that movie that I can't remember the name of Jesus
Christ,
his podcast sucks.
Uh,
yeah,
I really,
I,
you know,
I really can't like listen to,
to white people bitch about a white guys bitch about,
you know,
like affirmative action when they bitch about that type of shit.
All I can say is if you can't keep your fucking head above the line,
you know,
come on
really
if you fall,
you know,
do you know bunch,
you have to be fucking up as a white dude to get under that fucking line.
Like say colleges when they have that affirmative action thing.
So then somebody,
uh,
gets the same scores of view but they're not white,
so they fucking get in and you're going to sit there and Bitch Moaning Cup.
Come on.
Seriously.
Come on you.
You got enough fucking advantages.
You fucked up on,
you got to take that one on the chin.
That's how I view it and so I'm going to support that one cause I know it's also
going to bring a bunch of fucking emails so we can talk about race on the
podcast.
Something I would love to do.
All right.
Underrated.
Michael Vick.
Love him or hate him.
He's the best QB in the league right now.
Classic,
classic,
classic.
You see that right there.
There you go.
This is what this is.
That is the ESPN way of looking at football.
Did you watch Michael Vick last week against the hapless fucking Washington red
skins and their awful defense?
You would've thought Jesus Christ himself was playing fucking quarterback.
They would.
They could.
They say this is one of the most you're baking cake type every gig.
Michael Vick,
he,
Michael and Michael Vick jeep one fucking game in the middle of November and
this guy is suddenly,
he suddenly catapults fucking Tom Brady.
Peyton manning is as far as like all their accomplishments,
all the things that they've done.
He casts like two to two or three good fucking gains are right now.
He is the best QB and the fucking league.
Jesus fucking Christ.
It's just,
it just fucking unreal.
I get it.
He's the fastest fucking guy in the NFL.
You can't fucking tackle the guy.
I get it.
He stayed in the pocket now and he's actually doing what a quarterback is
supposed to be doing.
You know when the first guy is an open,
he doesn't take off and run anymore.
He looks for the second or third,
third guy open.
I get that shit.
All right.
And I'm not saying like somebody asked me last week when he was doing what he
did against the Redskins.
He said,
do you think this makes Michael Vick the best quarterback in the league?
I said,
look,
if he does what he did tonight against the fucking red skins,
like three weeks in a row,
he becomes without a doubt shoulder to shoulder with the best qbs in the fucking
league.
Okay.
But she got to win in January.
You got to lead your team and the fucking playoffs.
I'll rest.
It doesn't mean shit.
I mean,
yeah,
it's amazing.
The guy's fucking,
he's most athletic dude I have ever seen.
He's got an unbelievable army.
He has all the,
I'll tell you this,
he has all the fucking tools to become the greatest fucking QB of all time.
If,
if,
if he actually starts to play the position where he stays in the pocket and does
that without a fucking doubt.
But no,
he's not the best QB and the fucking league right now.
He,
he's not,
he's the most fucking amazing to watch.
I don't this,
this is,
okay.
This gets back to me when people think I hate the fucking jets.
This is what I hate.
I hate people who get crown king before they take the fucking crowd.
That's what I can't stand.
That's why I went off on Peyton last week.
That's why I'm going off on the jets this year.
You guys listened to his podcast for three fucking years.
I've made fun of the jets and that type of shit,
but it hasn't been like this year.
And the reason was was because that hard knock shit talk and that they did was
the most over the top disrespectful fucking thing I've seen in.
So God did it fucking Rex Ryan.
Yeah,
we'll go undefeated in September when and kicked the fuck out and then we'll
kick the shit out of those fucking day fucking guy.
And everybody's talking about how confident,
confident that guy was.
And I called him out on it and you know what?
I was fucking right.
I was right.
They weren't that fucking good.
And they still aren't that fucking good.
They are winning games at the last second.
They lost their first fucking game.
They lost to the ravens and they lost to the packers.
They've yet to play the colts.
Which a,
they're not really that good this year,
but they haven't played the fucking Steelers.
They haven't blown anybody away other than the fucking patriots.
What?
They're awful fucking defense.
So where do you get off talking?
All this shit.
That's why I'm giving him shit.
Okay.
I really don't give a fuck.
You know,
I give a fuck this year if they win the Superbowl,
but I don't get,
I don't wish that fucking misery on jets fan.
Do you really think I want you guys to go your whole lifetime and never win a
championship?
I don't.
All right,
but this year I don't want you to,
because you talked to all that.
You guys didn't talk all that Shit because Rex Ryan talked all that shit.
That's all this shit is about.
All right.
But other than that,
I don't give a fuck.
It's fun that they're good.
It's not fun when they suck.
That game against the culture yesterday wasn't fun because what's his cross?
Because Peyton Manning,
he didn't have all these guys.
It's not,
you know what I mean?
It'd be like beating the Yankees.
If a while,
Jesus,
their whole fucking team would have to go down the amount of fucking free agents
they sign.
Um,
it'd be like beaten.
Uh,
I dunno.
I Dunno what the fuck you,
you know what the fuck I'm saying?
All right,
so don't,
don't get like this whole thing,
you know,
switch.
I know.
I'd say over the top shit,
but I'm just trying to be funny here.
Right.
So all you kids who had taken this shit way too fucking seriously.
Speaking of which,
I got some audio,
few guys said,
one of my great listeners sent into me and I absolutely love this fucking audio,
but it's also embarrassing to me because this guy reminds me,
I hate how much I am just like this guy.
I hate that I give a fuck about sports as much as this guy.
Uh,
speaking of the eagles and the Redskins.
Okay.
And for my friends overseas,
either way,
uh,
there was a football game,
eagles played the Redskins in the eagles,
fucking rape the Redskins.
So this,
this radio host goes on the radio and has a 12 minute fucking meltdown
about all the shit he's had to endure as a Redskins fan,
which is kinda funny because they've won three super bowls in my lifetime.
So I,
part of it is hilarious cause he goes,
you know,
it's been 10 years of this shit and I just would love to see him do that rant
and get to that that moment.
And say it's been 10 years of this shit and say that standing on in in the
middle of Wrigley field when it's packed,
it's been 10 years of this shit.
Oh,
you poor fucking baby.
Um,
but it's actually,
to be honest,
it's been longer than that because you know,
it's been going on like 20 years and once you get,
you can start getting up around 20 years.
It sucks as a fan.
Um,
just talk to the Canadian fans up there.
You know,
it's starting to suck up there,
isn't it?
You guys gotta be,
you guys gotta be happy.
The Canadians look really good this year.
They have a really solid fucking team.
But the fact that the Canadians haven't worn it since 1993 and so unbelievable
that franchises,
they've never gone this long.
And the history of that,
of that franchise,
they've never gone anywhere near this long without winning a Stanley Cup.
Those fucking assholes,
I think right up until 1979 I think they had a better winning percentage then.
I think the Yankees,
I might be wrong on that now.
I think I'm Ah,
I might,
I think I'm right on that.
I think they were averaging winning one every fucking three one every three
years easily.
Ah,
fuck knows.
I'm bad at math.
But anyways,
so anyways,
this just go to the [inaudible] podcast.com.
This fucking rant is so funny and,
and first of all,
somebody sent the email and told me that this guy was going to go off and what
makes it so God damn funny is the way he starts the rant.
I thought it was just going to be some guy blowing a gasket,
but it starts,
he starts it so calmly.
He just starts off saying something to the effect of,
you know,
my grandfather was a Redskins fan.
He used to watch Sammy Blah.
He goes through his day.
He literally did background.
My Dad was a Redskins fan.
I've been a redskin fans.
I probably spent in my lifetime probably,
I dunno,
seven or $8,000 on throwback jerseys and Redskins merchandise.
He lays the fuck and groundwork.
He gives you the fucking backstory.
And then he just launches into this thing and I got to MIT,
man,
I got 10 minutes into it.
I just shut it off because I was so embarrassed that I have,
I've blown a gasket like this guy.
I mean,
he gets like seven minutes into it and I'm like talking to the guy like,
dude,
it doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter this much.
Just let it go.
And it's actually really funny except for this,
this guy in the background keeps going,
kid him kid who
Kitab and it really gets fucking annoying.
Other than that,
it's fucking hilarious.
Um,
all right,
52 minutes and let,
let's,
let's move on here.
All right,
this,
this fucking segment has really taken off.
I'm loving this one.
This segment is best line in a bad movie.
Uh,
and this week's video,
which is up on the Mlm,
podcast.com.
You got to watch this one.
Please do not have any food in your mouth when you watch this because you will
spit it all over.
A loved one.
Um,
watched the video.
Steven Seagal blood bank.
Uh,
just fucking awesome.
I really want to just go out one night and just rent five of the worst fucking
movies ever.
And just sit there and watch it with a couple of people that can appreciate it
because some of the lines of these fucking movies are incredible.
Please,
please keep sending me these videos because it's just making a nice long list of
movies that I have to sit down and watch.
Um,
you know,
is great for that,
by the way,
to you guys,
for fans at 30 rock and only get a name,
a name here,
cause this is something positive.
Uh,
Judah Freelander is an encyclopedia of knowledge on movies in general,
but forget about bad movies.
And if I remember correctly,
he actually collects them.
And,
uh,
I have to,
you know what?
I got to go,
I'm going to have him as a guest on this show and before he comes on,
um,
I'm gonna,
I'm gonna ask for his top five worst movies,
best worst movies of all time.
And I'm telling you,
he can break these movies down like Siskel and Ebert back in the fucking day as
to why their grit,
not why,
not only they're awful,
but they're also great.
Like he's a,
this is what one of the many things I miss about living in New York was running
into him and I would always bring up,
you know,
it all started one time I was,
I was hanging out at the comedy cellar and he was down there and I was trying to
remember this name of this Steven Seagal movie.
And I was like,
I was like,
dude,
what was the name of that movie?
Uh,
Steven Seagal had his,
one of his earlier ones.
And uh,
he,
he fought all those,
those fucking Bob Marley looking dudes and he just goes,
without even missing a beat.
He just goes marked for death.
Great movie.
And I go,
what was the plot of that?
He goes to plot of that movie is basically Steven Seagal beats up Jamaica.
I'm butcher and all this shit.
He said in a much funnier your way.
And then he,
then he broke down.
Why that movie was great.
And it basically came down to who said that movie introduced the breaking of
bones in martial art movies according to him or,
or took it to just an entirely different level.
And I'm telling you,
if you watch marked for death and you're squeamish,
uh,
that's not a movie to watch because I've never seen so many compound fractures.
Is that the compound fracture?
Is that the one where it,
it comes out through the skin?
That's the one I'm talking about.
All right.
And once again,
I start talking and I get in over my head.
This has been the easy listening podcast.
Um,
all right,
here we go.
Uh,
youtube videos for the week.
I can't remember if I put this one up last week,
but I'll look up the car.
James Brolin.
It's a,
uh,
one of the worst and hilarious trailers I've ever seen in my life.
This is another movie that I have to see.
A white line fever is another one.
Those are two bad movie trailers.
Um,
angry birds,
peace treaty
and a,
and here's another segment I'm going to introduce if you guys have all time
favorite classic youtube videos.
All right.
Look up food fight
and try to guess which wars that they're talking about.
I'm a more on the first time I watched it and just thought it was funny because
it was food blowing each other up.
And then I really started to see the,
uh,
the metaphors or was it the similes I never simile is using like her abs.
Well then they would have to say America is a cheeseburger.
That's a metaphor.
Assembly would be,
America is like a cheeseburger are at,
you'll understand it when you watch the video if you haven't seen it yet.
And uh,
as far as drummers goes this week,
this is another Stuart Copeland one,
and this is a band that I meant to get into.
And I don't know what happened.
I got so busy,
but,
uh,
oysterhead,
watch the Youtube Video Oz is ever floating as a performance that they did on
Conan O'brien.
And the band was Stewart Copeland on drums.
Um,
what's his face?
I just went,
I just spaced on his fucking name.
Trey,
uh,
the guy from fish,
I forget his fucking name and a stage.
Yo,
I was never a big fish fan.
Um,
I think they're awesome,
but I just can't listen to fucking 58 minutes songs and a on base was les
Claypool.
That was the band and they're fucking awesome.
And I'm going to download some of this shit.
All right.
And with that,
I think all the only thing we have left,
I'm going to end with advice,
which really seems to be the way that we end.
Do I have time for a couple of quick questions?
I don't think I do.
All right,
let's get to the advice for the week.
All right.
Question Bill.
Being a frequent flyer,
don't you uh,
think this controversy over the new body scanners is fucking bullshit.
Uh,
a guy hit a bomb in his fucking underwear.
What exactly do these complaining bastards expect us to scale back on security?
We have become so pampered and used to the utmost comfort that we are doing the
terrorist's job for them.
Who gives a fuck if someone is seeing your cock or your tits,
he or she is seeing hundreds a day.
Uh,
you sir are a fucking moron.
All right?
If you go through airport security,
I dunno if you've noticed they're not exactly the fucking navy seals,
although they have gotten better in the last couple of years,
but they don't,
you know,
they're always shooting the shit.
They're always fucking around.
They're not really paying attention.
It doesn't really look like it's a high paying fucking job.
Alright,
let's go with that.
All right,
let's go with secondly,
uh,
a body scanner,
entire body scan.
Let's get over the fact that you don't want a naked picture of yourself,
which is,
you're fucking right to not want that,
by the way.
All right?
Secondly,
I don't know about you,
but I fly every other weekend and when I go on benders like this,
at the end of the year,
cause I owe the bank are concerned,
the fucking government,
a bunch of money.
I go on like,
you know,
four or five weeks in row,
I fly.
All right?
So I got to get a full bond body scan,
uh,
on the way out and the way back.
You know,
I really have to start checking to see that I'm not going to be completely
filled up with memory on this fucking Olympus ls 10.
They have the God damn time right there.
I apologize.
Let me get back to what the fuck I was talking about.
Um,
yeah,
so,
so you're basically saying that I shouldn't complain that like six weeks in a
fucking row and a total of 12 times I'm going to take radiation from head to
fucking toe.
All right.
And don't even tell me,
oh,
it's only for fucking second to when you go to get your fucking,
you know,
teeth rayed they put that leather fucking,
that led vest leather,
that led vest over all your fucking Oregon's.
And then they go lay leave the fucking room.
And I was supposed to stand there like I met a Jay z concert and I'm getting
frisky at the same time with my fucking legs spread and doing that Jay z thing
over my head.
And they're going to know,
fuck that this cancer in my family,
I'm not doing it.
I'm not doing it,
pat me down.
So that's why I did the one on the,
on the way out.
I was like,
yeah,
I'm not doing that thing.
And I said to pat me down,
so then you know,
they did it and they said,
and they came up to me and this guy said,
I have to patch it down.
Uh,
are,
are there any parts of your body that are,
uh,
that are,
that are sensitive?
And I wanted to be like,
well,
I'm thinking all of us have areas of our body that are sensitive
to creep them out.
That was basically like,
no,
dad grabbed my balls.
I don't give a fuck.
Right.
I didn't know what he was going to do.
So he's puts on his dishwashing gloves and starts patting me down and they don't
grab your balls.
What they do is they go way up your inner thigh and he gives you your ball bag.
A little bit of backhand on each side of the ball bag,
you know,
so,
and I got to admit,
it made me laugh a little bit.
Yeah.
I don't give a fuck.
Yeah,
go fuck yourself.
Yeah.
You're not taking a fucking head to toe naked fucking picture of me as you,
as you know.
You're not,
you're not fucking radiate in my entire body so I can get on a fucking puddle
jumper to go to Hartford.
I'm not doing that.
Go Fuck Yourself.
Jesus Christ,
lazy motherfuckers.
You know
what people forget.
I,
so I don't get it.
You know what I mean?
This,
this is what I understand that they're,
you know,
quote unquote trying to keep me safe.
But what I don't understand is that people don't understand that during those
times of fear,
and let's try to keep you safe.
The amount of fucking like privileged that you lose and you never fucking get it
back.
And they always take a little more than they should.
That's why it's great that people bitch.
And it's great that you can bitch because if you bitched like this in China,
they'd probably put you to death and then harvest.
You're fucking Oregon's.
All right.
So yeah,
I think it's fine with the amount of fucking cancer that's out there and that
people fucking talking to cell phones all the God damn time.
You don't want to end it.
You know,
you don't want to add to it.
W with head to toe,
fucking Zappa,
fucking radiation.
You know,
I'm,
I'm standing there,
I don't have my fucking shoes on.
I'm stripped down to a fucking tee shirt.
I got jeans on and Shit.
I don't have anything on me,
you know,
and there's all this fucking flipping out about the fucking airplanes.
What about trains?
You could literally have a box that said,
I have dynamite on the side of it and you could see the fucking conductor would
help you it on.
There's no metal detectors.
There's no nothing.
Despite the fact that 15 years ago,
that guy got on the long island railroad railroad and shut that shut the whole
fucking thing up.
So I don't like that.
I don't like that whole fucking ice skate scan my retina shit.
No,
go fuck yourself.
I'm not doing that.
And um,
it's,
you're right dude,
if you have no problem with it,
you know,
good luck with your testicular.
Slash brain slash tongue slash throat slash big toe cancer if you fly all the
fucking time.
Like a lot of people,
I'm not doing that shit.
I'm not fucking doing it.
That's a,
they have fucked dead,
you know,
and you're acting like before this shit went down,
they haven't been keeping us safe.
You know,
they have been says nine 11.
Knock on wood,
nothing has fucking happened before.
Those stupid body scan is nothing has fucking happened.
All right,
we'll find everything is fucking fine.
You don't need those God damn things.
You know what's funny is if next week somebody actually does something,
the conspiracy theorists are going to say that the government did it because
people were refusing those body scanners.
All right?
That's just my opinion,
man.
I seriously,
you know,
I'm not trying to get head to toe radiation.
I get that they're trying to fucking keep me safe.
But you know,
if they truly wanted to keep me fucking safe,
they wouldn't be shooting the shit and joking the amount of fucking times that
they are when I'm going through.
All right,
and that happens a lot.
Specifically,
it's the person who's looking at the TV screen is talking about whatever and his
joking and laughing,
which you're going to do because they have an unbelievably boring fucking job.
I would be doing the same goddamn thing,
but if they truly gave a fuck,
they would spend a lot more money on the people that they get to do the security
rather than these new fangled fucking goddamn machines.
I'm not going through those.
Pat me Down,
give,
give my fucking my ball bag.
A couple of backhands with the dishwashing gloves.
I don't give a fuck,
but I'm not going to stand there.
Spread Eagle and end up with cancer or the taint.
All right.
But you know,
you guys want to do it.
Go ahead and do it.
I don't give a fuck,
but I hope enough of you say no so it doesn't become mandatory.
All right,
that's it.
let's get with the advice here.
All right.
Hey,
hey the Ed bill.
Uh,
I need your thoughts in this situation.
This girl I hooked up with was a freak.
Um,
I never banged her.
I just fingered her and got her off and she blew me.
Her ass was huge.
It was amazing.
She texted,
she texted me the next day and saying how amazing it was and how crazy she got
off and loved it.
I thought the next date,
our third was going to be the,
uh,
a fun sex fest.
No doubt about it.
But I don't know where she said she didn't want to do this anymore.
She was moving down to Irvine,
leaving her old apartment.
That was just a few miles from me and she said we wouldn't ever hang out again.
So she didn't stay in touch.
Uh,
the one time she,
she was meeting up with friends and Santa Monica,
my neck of the woods.
We texted back and forth and by the end of the night she flaked again.
Well,
wait a minute,
you said she's not keeping in touch.
I guess when she left,
she didn't keep in touch,
but then she texted you when she came back to town.
I'm going to have to assume that because I can't talk to you.
All right.
Said you're going to meet it the other night and then she flaked again.
She said she liked to rendezvous,
but of course she never did.
Then she asked me why I'm obsessed with seeing her.
I told her the truth that I had a fun time with her and we both had a blast and
she clearly got off and I figured we could continue this good thing we got
going.
I didn't directly say I want to fuck her,
but the point probably came across in the texting.
Uh,
I'm straightforward with woman bill.
I'm,
I'm also aware of how this girl's Ben and he left out a few words.
I'm assuming he's saying been messing with my brain.
I even told her I couldn't shake a rough,
I felt used,
but since we didn't fuck it wasn't a good use,
the mission wasn't complete hot sex on a platter and makes the mission and,
uh,
makes the,
makes the mission complete.
Jesus,
uh,
we don't talk anymore.
I haven't seen her and I'm bummed I never banged her.
I was hoping you might have some insight as to why she suddenly stopped seeing
me.
She wasn't faking it.
She was really digging me and suddenly she halted the whole operation before I
could banger what gives me help me out.
Please give me some insight.
All right dude.
Well,
I don't know are an eye so I can't really break it down that much.
Uh,
there's a number of reasons why she,
she could have done it all right.
He said the girl was a freak.
Look,
the fact that all she did was bang you and you're now Jones and four and you're
saying that she's a freak and everything.
Um,
and then out of nowhere she said she didn't want to do this anymore is one or
two things.
That's either a,
one of those,
those girls who fancies themselves a femme fatale and they liked guy getting
guys all worked up and then just drop in you like a fucking hot potato,
you know?
Um,
just to fuck with your head.
There are girls out there that like doing that.
Um,
but if I had to guess because she actually blew you and did bring you to orgasm,
I would say that this sounds like a bad girl trying to reform herself or for
people who are more liberal.
This is a woman who's had her fun and she's realizing that when she begins a
relationship,
the way she did with you,
that,
uh,
that it doesn't go anywhere,
but she still loves to fuck and she's fighting that.
So she moves.
Maybe she banged so many guys in that area.
She needed us.
She needed a new start.
So she's down there and fucking San Diego or wherever the fuck she went and now
she's,
you know,
she's being that girl,
I used to fucking blah,
blah blah,
but now I don't,
you know,
maybe she's looking for a husband,
so maybe that's why she did it.
I have no fucking idea.
Maybe she's lonely down in San Diego.
She misses her friends.
She comes back and in a moment of weakness,
she texts you and then she starts crying to her friends.
Go and look at it.
I'm going to hook up with this guy.
I don't even like them.
And then they're just like going through thin.
Don't do it.
You don't have to do this.
You're doing so good right now.
You're not being a whore.
And then she leaves you hanging.
But I'll tell you this right now.
You got to let her go.
All right?
You got to be like,
when it comes to women,
if you're just out there and you want to fuck you gotta be like a relief
pitcher.
All right?
You serve up a fucking meatball and they knock it out of the park.
You can't be throwing your next pitch thinking about the last one.
You got to let the shit go start over again.
So right now you need to do is go out and find another fucking freak,
which you know,
if you're straight forward with women like you are,
you kind of find one.
And if you really just take the time to try to break them down and see what
different kinds of women respond to,
you literally become like a fisherman and you know,
whatever kind of woman you looking for,
that's the bait you're tossing out there.
All right.
If you look at,
for a wife,
for a serious girlfriend,
you don't go to a meat market.
You know,
join a softball league,
take a cooking class as something like that.
Go with a good girls are,
you know,
or if you do go out to the meat market,
look at the one who's actually watching her alcohol intake.
The one who seems to be the responsible one,
responsible a wife,
a mother to your children,
right?
One.
It doesn't have her stuff all hanging out,
but you know,
if you're looking for a who with,
you know,
it's all kinds of places to go.
Actually,
the great thing about whores is they're everywhere.
That's what I love about him.
You know,
it's like bottled water.
You can pretty much get it wherever you go
now.
You know what I mean?
You've got the office whore,
you got the fucking,
the horror at the gym,
you know the one that shows up in full makeup and fucking,
you know,
works out on level one on the stair master
looking over his shoulder to see who's checking her out.
Right?
But that girl is a fucking nightmare.
Even if she blows you,
you're going to have makeup all over your lap.
Here's the funny,
I finally got to the funny a fucking hour and 10 minutes into the Goddamn
podcast.
Where was it all week?
You know what the reason why this podcast wasn't as funny as usual is because,
you know,
I was thinking about all the people who don't get to laugh in the world this
week.
You know this week when we're supposed to give thanks.
Hey England and Australia and Sweden,
I will throw in Denmark in that to what's up there?
Ireland?
Where do you say they're Madagascar?
Do you guys have any sort of weak like that?
We have a big feast.
What about the Irish?
You guys got to have some big thing that you know,
turns into some sort of drunken brawl.
Uh,
Jesus Christ.
Can you go with anymore Hacky Shit?
Eh,
let's go to Scotland and then you put your fucking skirts on,
right?
You're fucking scared of wearing coats.
Um,
do you guys have any days like that bro?
You supposed to do was just sit down and eat and then there always has to be the
Debbie Downer who just sits there and starts talking about the less fortunate,
you know,
or one of these fucking celebrities who has to do a little public service
announcement.
You know,
Jane this week and Thanksgiving,
let's not forget about those Colombian minors.
So wherever the fuck they were from,
oh wait,
they got rescued.
But still they were down in that hole for a long time.
I like how this is like the one time of year too,
when people all of a sudden go out and they want to feed a homeless guy.
You know,
I had a buddy of mine did that and he went down there and they thought that they
were all going to be fucking high five of them and they were actually,
they actually got pissed at him.
They're like,
well,
where the fuck are you are the other 11 months of the year?
He was like,
wow,
that's a good point.
Um,
all right,
that's the podcast for this week.
I want to thank everybody who came out to my shows.
Uh,
at the listener auditorium.
I was calling the listener,
the listener auditorium in,
uh,
Washington DC had an awesome time and a comics at Foxwoods.
If you live in that area,
the New England area,
you want to do a little bit of gambling and,
and see some really high quality comedy.
I saw who the fuck they've been booking.
They got nothing but a big time.
Acts up there.
It's a great place to see a show.
Definitely check that out.
And this weekend I'm going to be in Seattle,
Washington at the,
uh,
come on.
Where the fuck is it?
On November 27th,
I'm going to be at the Moore theater.
All right.
And that's a huge venue.
So there are tickets left,
so please when you're done,
Chow and could you please come out,
check out a show?
I would.
I would love it.
I got a brand new hour of stuff.
Paul Versey all in for Paul Versey is coming to the show.
He's going to be opening up and we're hanging around an extra day.
We're going to go to the a Seattle Seahawk,
Kansas City chief game on Sunday.
Make it a fucking weekend.
Hey,
and if there's any good places to eat up there,
if there's a,
the place that has the best burger or the sandwich or whatever,
let me know cause we're both not boozing and we want to go check out some shit
like that.
All right,
that is the podcast for this week.
God bless all of you.
Have a happy Thanksgiving if you're not in this country,
having a happy fucking Thursday.
All right,
that's it.
Have a great week.
Go Fuck Yourself.
[inaudible]
[inaudible].